On peut utiliser cette partie de Monopoly
comme métaphore pour comprendre la société
et sa structure hiérarchique
où quelques personnes
disposent de grandes richesses et d'influence
alors que beaucoup d'autres, non.
Ils sont beaucoup moins riches,
beaucoup moins influents
et ont nettement moins accès aux ressources.
Et ce que mes collègues et moi
avons fait pendant ces 7 dernières années,
c'est étudier les effets de ces types de hiérarchies.
Et ce que nous avons trouvé
dans des dizaines d'études
sur des milliers de personnes à travers ce pays,
c'est que plus le niveau de richesse d'une personne augmente,
plus ses sentiments d'empathie et de compassion s'amenuisent
et plus son sentiment d'y avoir droit, de le mériter
et son idéologie d'intérêt personnel augmentent.
Dans plusieurs sondages, nous avons constaté
qu'en fait ce sont les personnes plus riches
qui ont davantage tendance à faire passer la cupidité pour une vertu
et la poursuite de ses propres intérêts
pour une attitude morale et positive.
Mon objectif aujourd'hui est
d'aborder les conséquences de cette idéologie d’intérêt personnel,
de discuter de pourquoi ces conséquences méritent notre attention
et de finir avec ce que l'on peut y faire.
Certaines des premières études que nous avons faites dans ce domaine
portaient sur le comportement d'aide,
ce que les psychologues sociaux qualifient
de comportement pro-social.
Et nous voulions savoir
qui était plus enclin à aider une autre personne,
quelqu'un de riche ou quelqu'un de pauvre.
L'une de nos expériences consistait
à réunir dans un laboratoire
des membres riches et pauvres d'une communauté
et à leur donner à chacun l'équivalent de 10 dollars.
Nous avons dit aux participants
qu'ils pouvaient garder cette somme pour eux
ou la partager, s'ils le désiraient,
avec un inconnu qui resterait complètement anonyme.
Ils ne rencontreraient jamais cet inconnu et il ne les rencontrerait jamais.
Nous avons regardé combien les gens donnaient.
Les personnes dont les revenus étaient de 25 000 dollars,
parfois en dessous des 15 000 dollars par an,
donnaient 44% de plus à l'inconnu
que les personnes qui gagnaient 150 000
ou 200 000 dollars par an.
On a aussi demandé à des gens de jouer à des jeux
pour voir qui avait tendance à tricher davantage
pour augmenter leurs chances de gagner un prix.
Dans l'un de ces jeux, nous avons trafiqué un ordinateur
de sorte qu'il était impossible de dépasser
un certain nombre en lançant des dés.
Il était impossible d'obtenir plus que 12 dans ce jeu
et pourtant, plus une personne était riche,
plus elle avait tendance à tricher à ce jeu
pour obtenir des points et remporter 50 dollars.
Elle trichait parfois trois à quatre fois plus.
Dans une autre étude, nous avons regardé
si les gens seraient enclin à prendre des bonbons
dans un bol dont on leur avait clairement dit
qu'il était destiné aux enfants,
(Rires)
participant...
Ce n'est pas une blague.
On dirait une blague mais ça n'en est pas une.
Nous avons clairement dit aux participants :
« Ce bol de bonbons est pour les enfants
participant à une étude dans un laboratoire, à côté.
Ils participent à une étude, ces bonbons sont pour eux. »
Puis, on a simplement observé combien de bonbons les participants prenaient.
Ceux qui se considéraient riches
se servaient deux fois plus
que ceux qui se considéraient pauvres.
On a même mené une étude sur des voitures,
pas n'importe lesquelles.
On a comparé si les conducteurs de différents modèles de voiture
étaient plus ou moins enclin à enfreindre la loi.
Dans une de ses études, on a observé
si les conducteurs s'arrêtaient pour laisser passer un piéton
que nous avions placé devant un passage piéton.
En Californie, comme vous le savez tous,
car je suis sûr que nous le faisons tous,
une voiture doit laisser le passage à un piéton. C'est la loi.
Voici comment nous avons procédé.
Sur la gauche, un de nos collaborateurs
joue le rôle du piéton.
Il s'approche et la voiture s'arrête.
Et typique de la Californie : la voiture est doublée
par le bus derrière qui manque de renverser notre piéton.
(Rires)
Mais voici un exemple de voiture plus chère,
une Prius, qui ne s'arrête pas,
idem pour une BMW.
On a répété cette expérience sur plusieurs jours
avec des centaines de véhicules
et avons enregistré qui s'arrêtait ou pas.
Et ce que nous avons constaté :
plus le prix de la voiture augmente,
(Rires)
plus le conducteur a tendance à enfreindre la loi.
Aucune des voitures, aucune !
de la catégorie la moins chère
n'a enfreint la loi.
Par contre, près de 50% des voitures
de la catégorie la plus chère ont enfreint la loi.
Via d'autres études, nous avons constaté
que les personnes plus riches ont plus tendance
à mentir lors de négociations,
à avoir des comportements non-éthiques au travail,
comme se servir dans la caisse,
recevoir des pots-de-vin ou mentir aux clients.
Mais je ne veux pas dire par là
que seuls les gens riches
adoptent ce type de comportements. Pas du tout.
Au contraire, je pense que nous tous,
au quotidien, sommes constamment tiraillés
entre ces motivations concurrentes :
quand mettre nos propres intérêts
au dessus de celui des autres.
Et c'est compréhensible parce que
le rêve américain repose sur le principe
de l'égalité des chances devant succès et prospérité,
tant que l'on s'applique et travaille dur.
Quelque part, ça veut dire
qu'il faut parfois faire passer ses propres intérêts
avant les intérêts et le bien-être des autres.
Cependant, ce qu'on constate c'est que,
plus les gens sont riches,
plus ils ont tendance
à adopter une philosophie du succès personnel
où ils privilégient leur réussite et leur accomplissement
au détriment de ceux qui les entourent.
Voici un graphique qui montre
le revenu moyen des ménages pour chaque cinquième de la population
plus les 5% les plus riches sur les 20 dernières années.
En 1993, les différences de revenu
entre les différents quintiles de la population
sont assez flagrantes.
On voit clairement qu'il y a un fossé.
Mais ces 20 dernières années,
ce fossé s'est transformé en Grand Canyon
entre ceux au sommet et tous les autres.
En fait, le top 20% de la population possède
près de 90% des richesses totales du pays.
Ce sont des niveaux historiques
en matière d'inégalité économique.
Cela veut dire que
non seulement les richesses sont de plus en plus concentrées
entre les mains d'un groupe restreint
mais aussi que le rêve américain devient
de plus en plus inatteignable
pour une majorité grandissante d'entre nous.
Or, s'il est vrai comme nous le constatons,
que, plus on est riche,
plus on estime mériter cette richesse,
plus on fait passer ses propres intérêts
avant ceux des autres,
et plus on utilise toutes sortes de moyens pour défendre ses intérêts,
alors il n'y a aucune raison de penser
que ce modèle va s'inverser.
On a, au contraire, toutes les raisons de penser
que la situation ne fera qu'empirer.
Et voilà ce qu'on aura dans 20 ans
si les choses restent ce qu'elles sont,
si la situation connaît une évolution linéaire.
L'inégalité, l'inégalité économique
mérite notre attention à tous
et pas simplement par égard
pour les gens au bas de la hiérarchie sociale
mais parce que les personnes et les groupes
caractérisés par de grandes inégalités économiques
s'en sortent moins bien,
pas seulement les plus pauvres, tout le monde.
Il y a énormément d'études probantes
de chercheurs de haut niveau, partout à travers le monde,
qui montrent l'étendue des choses qui sont minées
quand les inégalités économiques se creusent.
L’ascenseur social, des choses qui nous tiennent à cœur,
la santé, la confiance sociale,
tout cela s'amenuise lorsque
les inégalités augmentent.
Parallèlement, les phénomènes négatifs
pour les collectivités et sociétés
comme l'obésité, la violence,
l'emprisonnement, les condamnations
s'aggravent lorsque les inégalités économiques se creusent.
Et ces phénomènes ne touchent pas qu'une petite partie de la société
mais la société dans son ensemble.
Même ceux au sommet de la hiérarchie en font les frais.
Donc que faire ?
Cette spirale infernale de comportements négatifs pernicieux
semble être devenue hors de contrôle.
Il semble que nous ne puissions rien y faire, certainement pas individuellement.
Pourtant, à travers nos propres recherches, nous avons découvert
que des interventions psychologiques minimes,
que de petits changements dans les valeurs des gens,
des coups de pouce dans la bonne direction
pouvaient nous ramener à un certain niveau en matière d'égalité et d'empathie.
Par exemple, rappeler les avantages de coopérer
ou de vivre en communauté
rend les gens plus riches aussi égalitaires
que ceux plus pauvres.
Dans l'une de nos expériences, nous avons montré à des gens
une courte vidéo de 46 secondes
sur la pauvreté parmi les enfants.
Cela leur rappelait les besoins des personnes dans le monde autour d'eux.
Ensuite, nous regardions combien ces personnes
étaient disposées à offrir de leur temps à un étranger
que nous leur présentions et qui avait un grand besoin d'aide.
Une heure après avoir vu la vidéo,
les plus riches étaient tout aussi disposés
à offrir de leur temps pour aider un tiers
que les moins riches.
Ce qui suggère que ces différences ne sont
ni innées, ni liées à une catégorie,
mais que l'on peut les modifier
par d'infimes changements dans les valeurs des gens,
une touche de compassion
ou un soupçon d'empathie.
Au-delà des murs de nos laboratoires,
nous commençons à voir des signes de changement dans la société.
Bill Gates, l'un des individus les plus riches de ce pays
lors de son discours à la cérémonie de remise de diplôme de Harvard
a abordé les problèmes auxquels notre société fait face,
l'inégalité en est le plus redoutable défi
et a parlé de ce qui doit être fait pour la combattre,
disant : « Les grandes avancées de l’Humanité ne sont pas ses découvertes
mais comment ces découvertes sont utilisées
pour réduire l'injustice. »
Et il y a The Giving Pledge [campagne aux États-Unis]
dans lequel plus de 100 des individus les plus riches de ce pays
s'engagent à verser la moitié de leur fortune
à des œuvres de charité.
On voit également apparaître des dizaines de mouvements
comme « We are the 1% » ,
« Resource Generation »,
ou « Wealth for Common Good »
dans lesquels les plus privilégiés de la population,
des membres des 1% les plus riches et d'ailleurs,
des gens qui sont riches,
utilisent leurs propres ressources économiques.
Jeunes et moins jeunes, c'est ce qui me frappe le plus,
utilisent leurs propres privilèges
et leurs propres ressources économiques
pour combattre l'inégalité
en plaidant pour des politiques sociales,
des changements dans les valeurs de notre société,
ainsi que dans les comportements des gens.
Cela va l'encontre de leurs propres intérêts économiques
mais ça peut finalement restaurer le rêve américain.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)